the last thing I was expecting to hear
was having a little bit of a half
classic sitcom vibe to it the show's
gonna be fill in the front of a live
studio audience
I wish yeah I know the first Marvel
movie where everyone just goes home by
6:00 be envisioned I told you to stop
phasing through the doors life and they
just have the most massive CGI set
pieces of any live studio shits like all
of its on a green screen with live
rendering what did you do now Wanda I
accidentally destroyed another building
where were these powers during the
infinity war what's up reject nation I'm
Greg album John Humphrey we know that
people are gonna be asking us for our
opinions on some of the Marvel
announcements from d23 we're gonna speed
through some of the stuff from Disney
plus some of the things talked about on
Saturday today where Kevin Feige took
stage give some quick opinions what
we're looking forward to why what we
hope from it blah blah blah you know how
the shindig goes before we do that I
wanted to thank everyone who has been
downloading and following us on the
Stardust app followers have been
increasing that so it was a good thing
over there we do thirty second reaction
reviews for any film TV show and/or
trailer we post weekly it's free to
download free to use you can post your
own videos too and tag us let's get this
one out of the way black panther - no
real details have been announced except
I think ryan coogler said he's submitted
retreatment for it and black panther 2
is not the official title no it's not
even though that was a logo that came up
on a Sun screen it's black panther
vision black panther one came out in
february this one's coming out May 20-22
so it's going from Black History Month
to white history summer blockbuster
history who's not white is Piderman oh
that's cool I mean I felt like when
phase four was announced at Comic Con
people were like what about Black
Panther to news what's going on so it's
cool to get that out of the way
story one damn we're going out of order
okay now let's swing back over or no
news about that hop on over to some
Disney Plus shows first one i think i
think that fur doesn't matter miss
marvel come all the con pakistani
character born in Jersey City we're
getting more diverse you know we got is
this this is gonna be like our first
Muslim MC you carry I'm excited for this
from what I hear about Kamala Khan you
know being a fan of the character
herself as a fan of like the Marvel
characters to call miss marble a I
thought was a little weird to have this
character announce so close to Captain
Marvel it's kind of strange to me to
have two characters so close to each
other you know Captain Marvel and Miss
Marlowe two characters the name Marvel
on the title I know that her characters
like a big admirer of Captain Marvel but
her powers are totally different yeah
yeah well maybe they just wanted to
capitalize on the age that young Carol
Danvers is now because you know when she
first transforms she's like girl danvers
so maybe they just want to get the
continuity with that actress yes they're
like let's get this going right now
I like your train of thought there
humpty dumpty appreciate that man her
powers the big highlights she's
basically Reed Richards got
shape-shifting abilities and you know
she'll glow a little bit that's new I
don't think they've confirmed that right
that it's Kamala Khan yeah it's just
safe to a smoke recent iteration of the
character especially based off the
director that yeah just make the most at
the point in time we're at I feel like
Disney and Marvel are both trying to be
more inclusive so this would just make
sense and from who the character is I
kind of wonder if it's a little bit like
female Spider Man in terms not in terms
of like picking up the mantle for
Captain Marvel or something like that
yeah but being at being a teenager
having struggles but being a fan of the
Marvel characters and wanting to be like
a Marvel superhero herself maybe
potentially become an Avenger one day I
wonder if it's gonna have a little bit
of those dynamics I [ __ ] heavily for my
Filipino cultures and that's not Muslim
but I can understand like cultural
clashes that often happen and I feel
like this character will explore that of
someone who has a
family from Pakistan but is a American
born yeah like they'll explore that a
little yeah who's kind of rubbing up
against her no culture and yet totally a
white person I'm continentally they're
always dealing with yeah like where does
my identity break free just be myself
nice speaking of white people oh yeah
nice white night is very I'm surprised
this was like the biggest takeaway it
seemed like from yesterday's panel
anyway that most people got excited
about but it seems like a cool character
I've heard it described is like what if
Batman had like split personality
disorder yeah kind of a neat idea you
would get M night Shyamalan glass yes
it's gonna what it sounds like but the
character being like more a little bit
unstable having multiple personalities
so kind of a competition of late David
done Kevin from yeah mercenary lots of
martial arts and he also has like to
alter egos so I got imagine they're
going to take advantage of that cuz he's
got the millionaire playboy side he's
got like a cab driver all three yes I
imagine too that for a show you're gonna
get like at least they said six episodes
for these so I think that'll be
especially depending on the actor they
choose I think that'll be a lot of fun
and I feel like it'll be a little bit
more of a grounded supernatural take on
a Marvel character if that is an
accurate assessment from IGN that is
kind of like a Batman type story but
with a twist it would be cool to see
Marvel work now in that tone and to do
it with it like a character like this
really intrigues me because of that
supernatural element you've got like an
ancient god involved his cape is even
like a burial shroud like I love stuff
like that this actually seems really
cool to me the one that I expected to be
the most talked about simply because
this character out of the Disney Plus
new announcements is definitely the most
well known one of the three is a she
Hulk Jennifer Walters pretty much only
been Jennifer Walters Barbara Walters
Barbara Walters it's that's inspired by
yeah just always making villains be my
and admit their leo deepest personal
thoughts criminal lawyer cousin of Bruce
Banner
except you know when she morphs into her
Hulk version she remains freakin hot man
yes she sexy challenging and witty yeah
yeah Mark Ruffalo might appear in it
considering who the character is I
wonder if it'll be distracting if you
know if they go by comic book
origins it to have mark ruffalo up here
and like the first episode of this
because I feel like if you do that you
might just be like I want to see Mark
Ruffalo in this whole thing yeah and you
and you really want to give all the
attention to Jennifer Walters yourself
and then have Mark Ruffalo appear later
on as opposed to like right away yeah
and that's something I wonder about
these shows too because there are
potentials like I believe there is at
least one version of the story where
like she's trained in combat by Captain
America and Gamora I don't know exactly
where this falls in the timeline but you
could at least get Gamora involved or
something you know yeah if she's she's
you know she's back now sort of yeah and
I you know they haven't announced any
news of what they would want to do with
daredevil down the road got a new lawyer
character now well so I think it's a
good time to introduce she-hulk after
having Professor Hulk an endgame where
you have a more articulate intelligent
version of the Hulk she-hulk still
possesses that when she's in that form I
don't expect to see her argue the law in
she-hulk form yet because I think that
would be kind of too much for season one
but I would love to like one thing I
liked about daredevil that kind of fell
off over time was that it was kind of a
legal show - yeah so again in the game
of mixing and matching flavors for
Marvel I think that could also be a cool
element is yeah you have all your
she-hulk badassery but you also have
some of the legal side because you know
we have so many characters who have cop
alter egos or whatever and so yeah
somebody involved in criminal justice
seems like just a neat spin a little bit
more whan division favorite title I love
it apparently the show that's supposed
to have a little bit of horror to it is
also gonna be half classic sitcom half
MCU spectacular the three houses it's is
it's two three three things like that
how long are the Epis is gonna be a half
hour I heard on the panel on the I don't
know if it's like actually within the
show but I heard on the whatever they
were showing that they were splicing it
was like Dick Van Dyke footage if that
was like footage they showed or if that
is a thing they're gonna be doing the
series is just stock footage for the
going off of a memory here what I read
but kat dennings is Darcy lose
turning and so is Randall Park agent woo
I love the Randall parking kat dennings
that's exciting yeah there are other
returning you know those were the
characters we were like we got to get
them what happened everything looks fine
put them in put them in there CBS ago I
want I want to show all about Michael
Pena's character from ant-man he should
be in here he should have what no
ant-man three announced well swing
around back to what if and Falcon a
Winter Soldier in just a second but
let's take a sidestep here to talk about
two major announcements Black Knight
played by Kidd Harrington who really is
trying to steer his career in a
different direction
totally totally break and I like Game of
Thrones mold I wonder if it's weird for
him coming in and seeing Robb Stark and
me like oh you get the spacesuit well
Black Knight I'm excited to see whatever
kid Harrington can bring to the role
from the basic things I've read about
him sounds like he's a good fit for it
special it was just make sense the ebony
blade that he wields is something
special is own sort of Excalibur of sort
an enchanted and destructive ball can
absorb and deflect energy the other big
announcement was that Gemma Chan who was
in crazy rich Asians over who is in
Captain Marvel is going to be Cersei and
that's who everyone thought Angelina
Jolie might be playing Black Knight and
Cersei do have a romantic relationship
in the comics and you bet that's most
likely gonna be included here I think
this is the first time we're seeing this
in the MCU specifically a person to play
a character and then play a different
character I know within the the MCU
I felt like Chris Evans yeah I know that
alfre woodard was in Civil War and then
she played a Mariah Dillard and the Luke
Cage series and then you got my her saw
the play caught a mouth who's gonna hop
on to playing blade but MCU can fight
really care whether nothing shows it so
that's different than this because
especially to be so close together to
which is kind of odd I don't feel like
it will ultimately be distracting
because it's a completely different look
yeah
this GOP greenus she wasn't all that
memorable of a live-action portrayal in
Captain Marvel yes there I hope for for
her to be like play a different
character she's able to really shine a
lot more her character I think still
existing to right I remember Captain
Marvel Captain Marvel so she's gonna be
playing two characters at once or as the
franchise's that are going I mean and
then when Captain Marvel crosses over
with the Eternals is gonna get real I'm
gonna get really confusing in going back
to Disney Plus they showed some footage
of what if they had one with a Peggy
Carter as if she was Captain America or
they call her Captain Karger and Captain
America was rocking some kind of like
1940s Iron Man suit or something like
that
which sounds cool they said they're
gonna be doing a what-if of every Marvel
movie like a different rendition of it
so there's gonna be 23 episodes I
believe I really wonder how that's gonna
go down because they're gonna do
something just brand new unique thing I
don't think they're doing what ifs of
the Avengers movies they're gonna do
what ifs of endgame yeah you know III
don't think that's the paths are going
down
Marvel Zombies I think it's Winter
Soldier who's fighting Captain America
yeah that's that's gonna be cool and
only way we're gonna ever get that so
yeah it's gonna be that's something
people have kind of wanted as just a
nerd fantasy for years and I'm glad that
they like actually are acknowledging it
but this is one of the things I think
I'm just most excited about for the
potential alone and also just some of
the weird like character remix it's like
then they say two challahs gonna be
star-lord and one of them completely
like huh what are you well yeah I heard
you that I was talking I was like is
this are these what ifs the people like
have collectively mused or you literally
just go out I don't know what if this
guy was just that guy I mean I always
like that improv game yeah back at ya
sweetie
Scott Lang was Gamora that could happen
I like it I like I wanna see that
version yeah he's got a whole thing with
Thanos it's perfect
and then Falcon a Winter Soldier
announced that uh Kurt Russell's son
Wyatt Russell who I
was pretty damn good in black mirror and
Overlord he's gonna be playing John
Walker u.s. agent 2 in the comics went
by super Patriot at one point did dawn
the Captain America mantle I think at
times he does have a little bit of
difference in philosophies or mindset as
opposed to Captain America but over I
think is true America man I don't know
much about him maybe Curt helped him get
the role or maybe he's just a good actor
maybe just a good actor but I don't know
I mean it'll be cool to see him get
super jacked more than he is already
those are all the d23 Marvel
announcements that was a quickest we
could skim through all that which news
here excited you the most leave a
comment down below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell you can check us out
on the star dough step and I'd like to
give a page for the day shout out to a
man named Josh Walker the super Patriot
yes oh no John that was John Wow this
gentleman we've shown before that he's
an ultimate cosplayer man does he really
commit to it he also runs a site for a
high-end self catering holiday so Disney
Marvel if you're looking for someone to
help cater to all your famous
celebrities at your little cons where
you don't release the footage online
right away that reactor's wait around
all day for this is your guy he might be
a little bit creepy and I'm only calling
him creepy because he's been pledged for
a while and I sent him a message a few
weeks ago a few paragraphs he hasn't
replied back to me yet and usually to
get the attention of someone who hasn't
reply back you just got to insult them a
little bit Josh I want you to stop being
a pervert message me back as soon as you
can hands on the keyboard my friend and
not on the lap and not on the lab lady I
must write without a yellow dollar bill
science that we're trying to avoid some
keywords right now yes oh you said [ __ ]
though it's all done damn it well Josh
Walker on a serious note stop touching
yourself you're gonna you're waiting
here